wow look at you you lost so much weight
are you are you talking to me
what do you think i'm talking to look at
you you look like a new man
how much did you lose uh so far about
35 pounds bit more are you working out
uh i'm trying to but i suck at it i'm so
bad at it it's terrible i hate it
there's so few hours in the day yeah
just
my own do you know what i mean i've got
three young kids
we have the show and all these things
that i feel like hang on a minute
i've got an hour here where i'm on my
own and i'm doing something that i
absolutely hate i should just be
lying down you know i should like
you know that's the thing you know when
people go oh i can do nothing i don't
believe them
i can do nothing
i'm talking about like lying on a couch
and staring at the corner of a rug
you're absolutely right i get up and the
day goes like this especially days that
i'm i'm on the radio but i also don't
trust
personal trainers is what i've realized
i don't trust them
i don't think they want me to lose
weight quickly because really i've must
have burned through
in my lifetime i reckon 75 personal
trainers right
and i'll turn up and they'll go okay
what do we want to do
and i'll go i just want to lose like 40
pounds and they'll go all right
listen it starts up here okay it's
starting up here
are you ready to get it you ready to
make that change and i go
yeah i [ __ ] i am and then look at they
go look at me man we're in this together
we're gonna we're gonna burn this 40
pounds
in a second and i'm like all right let's
do it okay and they pump me up
let's get some music on and they put on
like jay-z or something and i'm like
this is here i'm making the change and
then they'll like
put an elastic band around my knees and
be like
okay just do this there we go
that's it and i'm like i don't you ain't
losing enough
this isn't gonna burn 40 pounds
i'm lucky if this will burn a pound a
week and then i realize oh
you're paid by the hour of course you
don't want me to shift this quickly
have you gotten to the point where you
bought new clothes or are you afraid to
buy new clothes well
for some time now i've had three
separate wardrobes
three three sections of a closet so like
you're an embarrassment there's a
section that says you gotta do better
and there's a section that says
yeah baby you're really doing this and
that section on the far right has not
been used in a while so i'm quite
enjoying
dipping into some of those some of those
clothes
but uh no i've not bought masses of
clothes because i'm hopeful that there's
still a way
to go the bottom line is too it is what
you eat do you know the issue honestly
my [ __ ] hands my hands are the
problem
my hands will reach for food that they
know i don't want
to take the food cut those things off
that's what i like honestly that's the
best diet i could do would just strap my
arms to my body
and i think i would shift this weight in
a heartbeat
to be clear i just want to make this
absolutely clear anyone who's just
listening to this on the radio and not
watching this if they see me on tv
tonight they're going to go
he's [ __ ] talking like he's lost a
load of weight he's still fat
like i'm not sound like tell him to shut
his [ __ ] mouth
yeah like i'm the rock over here like
how did i get in this phenomenal shape
like
i don't look good i just look better